this is for video shoots but we're back
yeah we're back and we're gonna make up
for it by playing a couple episodes yeah
that sounds good watching this it's
probably like midway through a week
we're planning on ideally yeah making a
lot of promises as we do like more and
more travel Mike you running reboot and
I'm producing a couple live shows at to
which we're getting pretty busy but it
will not stop us from finishing this
series we hold so dear oh yeah hey girl
alright here we go alright I don't know
where we are in the story I just know
that I've ran from hecka zoms recently
yeah so uh oh we're oh yeah we just got
through that initial Elgin we haven't
gone very far it's gonna be weird for me
because I'm listening to your audio I
figured that would be easier than
letting a not doing it you want that mo
no sure yeah so people gave us a few
tips and I forgot about so fruit piles
you can smash for the most important one
I heard was that if you stand near me
and I heal it feels both of us which is
super important and I cannot believe you
didn't know that picture of mine well no
it's not both of us it's just I can heal
you I'm totally wrong it is both of us
sweet okay ah we're back
man it's been a while so played this
continue putting your suggestions in the
comments I do read them because I do not
trust my mic yes
tell me put my grenade on okay nope
nevermind sorry I didn't know it was
gonna hurt dummy okay oh this is your
cold brew I drink all my ah yeah it's
mine sweet that looks like if I shoot it
a little blow up uh yeah don't do that
hon come here don't don't move farther
there's some cut yelling [ __ ] over here
got an herb herb Phillips uns
is that a name it is this like outdoor
kind of department store in upstate New
York it's a very very obscure reference
that is really triggers it's going this
furnace room okay wait not yet hon I
picked up a furnace key nice got hand
Guyana I'm just picking up all the [ __ ]
I'll share with you later
yeah I'm sure you will well the old
trickle-down effect a are you going here
I will take all know what the [ __ ] what
just press that yeah why I don't know
you almost blocked me the furnace don't
go in there and close the doors and no
sorry I don't I'm not convinced that was
unintentional oh it kills you go back
this way follow Sheva what oh you must
kill you needed melted me oh my goodness
cast it into the fire all right go dope
dope dope don't pinch we got some [ __ ]
going down I remember this uh-huh she
has been a zombie this whole time no oh
no
Oh what is that yeah I forgot it
Pluto borrows like Kojima's lakhs game
you [ __ ] man
[Music]
I think that's what got Alpha Team
[Music]
when do we get to cook right so you have
any ideas what we can do this dude yeah
we um hit it with the fiery thing this
is much easier on co-op when Sheva can
be done or did this barrel right here
where we run through right let me act
you this we owe that yeah one of us can
lure man but I'm just gonna use make use
of this first - is he coming oh yeah
it's on its way
what do you mean one of us lures him in
don't we both have to be in here
no they lure the lever it takes like two
seconds to uh there's a pretty good time
between oh let me get in quick
she Atum oh [ __ ] it's still coming are
you going all right
whoo but you got to press the lever like
I'll tell you when
okay i'll Lerman then get near that
lever I'm just making sure that he's not
okay great [ __ ] now he's that's the door
won't close
why not I mean it will but it won't
close by the time he gets out yeah like
bit members the door took like three
seconds to close yes everyone yeah okay
you all are you get stand by the if so
this is what weird you got I gotta learn
you have to learn in and I'm gonna be
right behind him though I am the lover I
was last time and you were life all make
the call because I yeah yeah okay but
you were too slow hello you wrote a
letter right now I can't no I meant like
a guy dodged him go press it go
president thank you should stay always
coming to you George
whoa I'm sweeping all right oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I'm not are you in it uh I got out
okay I ran a better he comes and gets us
we were both gotta kind of lure him in
uh Lindsay doesn't with me right Marty
oh but all right I got ya get out there
all right I got I got a bunch of worms
on you are covered in here what do I do
but his words yes lemon here and then
right you let me know all this coming
through all right
press press press press reckon on it so
there is a cool down I don't know if you
know that [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah this shit's doors are closing and I
know get out yeah suck fired dick
that was what I mean
idiot too much alright so I don't think
that's it it's really convenient that
this room's I'm here
Louise vomiting vomiting slurp ah do me
a favor
Yeah right okay no slugs alright we did
it yeah success great guns go check out
the body check his clerk for me nothing
there's nothing that is nothing
what if Sheva was German that is nothing
it wouldn't really make much sense for
the story the the mb8 my schnitzel and I
must take revenge my country of Africa
that was did you mean to do a Russian
accent yeah and I'm mixing them all now
not so furnace key that's me I don't
know what time we start recording five
minutes ago about 6:30 ish know which we
wanted to we had some technical issues
before they started I'm gonna say well
you don't always start when you should
like what
that's not events I didn't do a good job
um we we couldn't connect I kept like
rejecting your connect oh yeah by the
ps4 Resident Evil 5 has some weird
issues on so we were like so just oh
we're not on you know we must not be
connected to the internet or like maybe
like PS Plus issues like we checked all
this stuff just turned out we just had
to do it 10 times and it worked on the
10th time we didn't do anything
differently so I'm sure that's in a
forum somewhere keep your eyes peeled
Chris
let's go like I just looks like a bad
guy
which one driving or in the passenger
seat the guy with the face
I forget have you beat just going before
no okay what was that thing vo w that
scumbag
Irving left behind to set us up
considering what it did to Alpha Team I
think we're lucky to still be breathing
Chris is always coming in and gotten
there sooner behind alpha teens that get
[ __ ] out of would be dead lucky
doesn't he Bravo Team Bravo Stars team
yeah imagine that's my goal is always be
brother to him to get away with that
first of all guys this whole town's gone
to hell the people here they're acting
like those ganado detailed in the
Kennedy report and aside from that
there's something about something we've
never encountered huh
do you think that's something an army
does like they're like what kind of like
like our scrubs and Alpha Team and all
the good ones and in the second one so
usually you put the best people up front
wait we're the only two left you want us
to go in there alone
wait we can't I did not stand for this I
will throw waves and waves at men at
this yeah feeling you're expendable all
the time are we falling in love and this
cutscene mm-hmm get back to it enough
that German thing
well that's quite chapter we did it I
got a you got a trophy nice all right
touchpad that [ __ ] no no I don't quit
sorry wrong pocket novels careful I took
a long time for us to set this up us
option not touch bet some of us can read
all right good money to buy anything
worthwhile
ooh assault or that we could have picked
up a scorpion back at that ax dude fight
when we buy a gun does it go to both of
us no we share money but we spend it
separately if I'm not mistaken that's
dumb I think I'm good with guns actually
there's a you feel good with like the
original there's an SMG here you've got
similar money me we missed that I should
be back for the axe fight but I'm good
okay
oh wait I have SMG ammo that I don't
need those would put that into my can
you say so I could sell it I'll put down
here though like it won't eventually i
likey I likey shotguns
does it take two spots should the
shotgun no one
it's just each circle is an item that I
can shock it would be helpful to have
can i buy it this is funny it's like
what happens when you get like in a
serious relationship when you like share
your expenses and you're like anything
over 2,000 gold we have to decide
together we should buy it we do have
stuff to sell cool but yeah don't ever
say you and I are in a relationship
again but I'm just I'm selling this
stuff
yeah manage your own finances he will
but we have a shared bank account yeah
yes oh okay cool so now what do I have
how do I put in my inventory uh go dad
just go to that I could get emelius
don't want that okay I got it
interestin provides protection against
melee attacks but I don't need that yet
okay all right so I got some money I'm
ready I'm confused
you want health okay I am I have a spray
and an herb I have this machine gun ammo
and I can't use it
I just saved my two down inventory go
press r2 you have treasures to sell back
out of the SMG first there you go oops
uh do I have to be in the buy menu now
should be organized okay go to down yeah
there you go
so I sell these yeah
you I in this game is not as streamlined
you know it's weird I think in for it
was better like this is like kind of a
step backwards okay I'm ready
ah all right you have 60 seconds oh my
god that cans to comply so stressful
then we launch the bomb okay sick let's
do this how do I change no I don't want
to restore health yeah what do I do
I mean I don't want to do this uh
triangle what's up here oh look
okay so triangle get up here
triangle is organizing got it about to
pick up oh I got an emblem for here look
it I don't know you are hold r1 I
believe you see where I am
I liked having it on the hardware -
without your weapon out but I'm up here
there's an emblem right there you shoot
the using are those sick got some cool
for ya there those blue medallions and
for that you're shooting for a little
bit toward the beginning of the game
first like happy cry circle to call your
partner you can take us the mp5 over
here gun right here wait how long come
get the search thanks come on okay come
on come on come on come on come on no
what you think come at come home yeah I
get this mp5 I keep accidentally doing
their own thing sweet uh sweet you got
that I got some crate there you can hit
making sure treat document
so yeah the more emblems you shoot you
can get like outfits and stuff for both
people I let's blow this popsicle stand
I'm gonna try to Knight this rat all
right I'm gonna leave get him over here
nice woman
they won't come to me well I have to
hand it to them they have some good
survival instinct mmm
best circle on the dollar
no I don't mean that anymore like I'm
confused why you keep doing that
I think it's cuz I'm hitting left on the
d-pad that's probably why all right
let's go
compress Circle the Ducks wait Joe I got
it okay I understand that
yeah are you doing I'm learning how to
use things whatever our claim islands I
get such a nostalgia what Oh abusive go
go Roger
oh come on I'm sure the best of them
you're like my name is Shiva wait wait
wait okay enough of that because there
are trip mines up here oh okay don't go
next to my much shoot it look up there's
a guy with it also
yeah wait for the square to pop up
rather than our traditional l1 knife
thing are you bad wait for the square
yeah the square prompt instead of
actually manually no he's got a flame
across so of course it goes he was in
the shadow with a crossbow oh he ran
away it's on a trip for others dude
right here kill
and shrimp well you did up I got across
most through the left on their stuff
over here we are back gonna get the
stuff on the other side of this tripwire
oh I'm full there's an herb over here do
you want it
I guess my invite you yeah I'm gonna
kill this crossbow dude
he did oh I'm full of ham gonna land
there's a lot overdue um our to show you
where I am I see you there's stuff up
here though - I'll be right up you get
that um what about so did you see the
herb on the right no hey listen I want
you to get this herb
it's over here dude the crossbow would
you kill him come on
wait I'm full thanks uh can we get rid
of it I gotta be here I'll get it all
right got it
I just combined a couple herbs we're
good it's pretty smart so did you kill
the crossbow I did kill him [ __ ] oh
my god it's my old nemesis ha ha ha ha
we meet again
Oh Oh
all right shotgun I gotta I gotta get
[ __ ] them I got this dog I got him Oh
gross crossbow dude up top watch out aah
but nice alright keep mind if you have
those weapons in the top bottom we're
right or left slots in your inventory
that's quick select on your d-pad
[Music]
first dates right here if you want some
maybe I should use it I actually lost a
lot of help just then do you want to
come over here and I'll heal you while I
heal myself sure
so wait can I heal you and me yep just
press a single partner did that kill me
less than a healed you look a little bit
like that yeah dama that should hold
myself yeah you open up some space
you're in vent wow there's a trip line
right there I'm gonna get this go see
what's over here
damn it damn to see the new oh [ __ ]
gather wrench you see the new trailer
for that one night only in theaters
resin evil CG movies Dom Milian and
Chris I think post resin evil six or
seven even but it's like John wick like
Leon is dodging it Dom bees holding
their live another one a headshot man
yeah but it's like gun kata if you've
seen equilibrium it's dumb
and just what I'd expect from Liana's
Kennedy I gotcha
whoa I saved you save I may be mistaken
but at this point in the Resident Evil
storyline Leon Chris have never met
they've been in like Raccoon City around
the same time but they're still
strangers from what I understand like
you just said the Kennedy report from
the Spain is like Jodi's got a wrench oh
he's about to throw one [ __ ] [ __ ]
right you got two wrenches he's got a
wrench in his pocket in case that other
wrench doesn't work out well like I hit
me well I forgot because he has more fat
on him he's why can't I quit turn around
[ __ ] this guy dogs huh Opie this case
well I gotta reload help me
haha okay I got you well he's alive big
dog
yeah okay got some gold bangles mmm
Ellsworth at gots dummy didn't react oh
no oh wait Adam nice
yes who is doing that thing this face
it's two phases oh I got you
alright Sweden that's such a gross thing
to do
whoo crossbow event crossbow all he's
got Molotov let me get this I got it ha
ha ha
burn you son of a [ __ ] headshot man
it's not dead it just shot him
machete I would not do crepes machete
and I know that is slice that's the
second time I burned him alive thank you
i charred him now he like survives
crossbow dude well let's have fun it's
dude let me get him okay
nice nice kit now you get him okay
didn't work on that now you too he's
dead we got it damn doc rabri these
coming from can i headshot or can i do
the kick move to the dog ah good
question I don't remember I don't think
so at their recovery was really fast
hi sweet so that was we didn't get to
use those feel drums but we kind of feel
like no we didn't know
um this dude that I killed a Molotov had
something rich in gold sweet sweet
all right now what are we doing this
gate over here I'd assume Circle it up
Shiva wait hold on wait wait
okay okay Roger
come on so sorry for people watching uh
uh sweet let's get some food some of
these crates open I love how you can't
see that [ __ ] until uh I'm gonna combine
that quick red green right place is
[ __ ] up oh okay probably some sort of
barrels thank you the shot don't work
out yeah did ya
[Music]
I think I'm dead I feel like you did die
but I feel like you shot the bear like
your school shot one barrel I wonder how
much you have to redo we just got to a
checkpoint just ready up right now um
that was weird yeah I thought we got it
uh yaks it cuz I like great huh
maybe don't jump across yet or jump back
first can we jump back here I don't know
I remember this [ __ ] at all yeah nope we
cannot so let's just shoot him really
fast I guess so I think I could have
been a little faster
every that looks like alright sweet
okay I was always trying to jump back oh
sweet another barrel gotta work out Hank
it is dead zombies in space Oh
hard core gives me use me I don't see ok
I don't love either Chris or Sheva so
I'm gonna make up these new characters
I'm a mad German scientist who harvests
souls to bring back to my space station
go on uh so so take this for instance
give me your soul oh I guess I get speed
somersault space a ninja that takes
something else we're square oh right
hi uppercutted nothing sky the crossbow
give us a break please do it
zombie so much
night him what can you get that
crosswalk guys I'm just gonna distract
him
cool you're taking your side of it
whoa freak I was testing his AI guess
alright turns out if you get really
close to him he just continues to point
a crossbow all right here we go
some of us tell me there's a some sort
of farming glitch and breath of the wild
where if you go into this one field or
drop into a field and the bow cabins on
the horses are circling you
they'll keep shooting arrows at you and
others miss you know even if you stand
still so you just pick up the arrows
afterwards once they've created I
thought you could only pick up like
three arrows and then after that it was
like cool and then the arrows maybe
that's the glitch I don't know I don't
know man I got a lot of handgun off cuz
I've definitely let him go looking like
mom doing okay 13 bullets but I can
always change to my shotgun right oh
good and I also have that house any five
yeah I sweets for then I got a little
bit going on not doing come Chris I
smell souls of this sewer super-fit I
don't like your new character oh right
there with you Sheva oh no i let's
rethink what we're doing what's back out
oh they're coming from behind us do that
spot come on I've got no shotgun shells
left you're gonna have to check on them
thank you you're welcome
all right sweet wait wait let's heal I'm
really I'm in danger zone now no to
harvest these okay wait wait I need to
heal okay do you want to heal me heal
I've made it myself uh I'll do this
regular one to here come here come here
sweet brain my butt
and then what's huge
suck bullets suck wet the little jerks
he's a big jerk I was a huge dog many a
little puppy with him I don't feel great
about that actually I'm not it I'm not a
zombie dog person
I prefer Australian Shepherds I like
friends double dog rat get it
[ __ ] him you shun yeah shot him I mean I
fit a few more rats that be a lesson to
the rest of you rats that's great I feel
like the rats are a big part of whatever
character you're working on that must be
sold on the other side so I did a look I
did a live show a really long time ago
with Chris waters where he made a
history for me that I marry the Rat King
Kish my dad was like a rat breeder and
that's like where I got my family
fortune yes I'm liking it so far
um reignite that so the Rat King
Carl the Rat King and that's not even my
dad's name oh [ __ ] you did a great aid
or something what is that
they like exploded like they had gala
excited me I'm gonna take that shotgun
and with you don't mind sweet shoot him
I'm gonna reload I forgot to shoot him
sorry thanks I stabbed him he's [ __ ]
die stay down
was that shocking you think hey stop it
I want shotgun a Latino one shotgun em
logs yeah he's normal I swear him
there's [ __ ] in his body you those
things are gross hey do you want this
hand go on mo I'm full
why do I have to shoot that really I got
it
I'm not knife it damn it alright yeah I
do
wait hold on there's a gem back here
sapphire see you later sucker gonna
laugh when you die good laugh you die
alright brat
what kind of souls call a place like
this home that's like definitely stolen
it's not it's I think I'm just mimicking
like a blood biforn kind of characters
voice check out beyond you to look out
for emblems there's this dude that's
like super angry but he doesn't know
where um okay something like the work
some chainsaw guys coming to mind at
this part so tread carefully alright can
you take that bet herb oh you see if I
can come in right now click nope can bin
I'm I am disappointed actually starts to
say combine in later games um there is
another herb over here come on yeah I
get it
I'll leave that now
ah the beach so wonderful this time of
the year
do you want go swimming oh you can go in
the rat Kings right the ocean
alligators [ __ ] wait what is this not
that part no what what part where do
these oh we have to go in here okay that
makes Dewey there something that must be
hidden something around here Oh got it
Gold 100 of them keep keep searching fan
out
she's like what the hell was that who
was that shot my friend you bestfriend
killer I just got a topaz hey guys just
leave something to be desired
they are zombies um okay go back up here
I guess that resemble we're missing for
a few some fruit stacks it sounds great
fruits tax not fruit snacks Oh shocking
Emma I'll take that all right
yeah there's fuel drums lying around
keep that in mind I'm gonna get a red
herb really quick that's crazy good
running yeah they're kind of don't
follow them yet why not cuz it's
obviously a trap you play the first four
games you should know this I don't
understand uh here let me give you a
shock animal quick here
don't blow that yeah I gotta get this
why because you're triggering things
left and right when I'm trying to the
only thing on the screens that move all
over the place you are and there's fruit
snacks all over the place you're pushing
my buttons you scan this area see you
he's been hanged from the ceiling damn
that guy's hung oh that is gross there's
teeth I might be a cop again something
shooting me down and then and I don't
think you have to
well yeah
picked up portkey oh thank you I
triggered a cutscene all right I did the
thing he didn't sit on and his friends
his dual reg wailing friend all right
let's go whoa oh the guys right there
they did not care whether I was in that
building or not there's a guy right next
yeah that's what I was talking about you
get out of that house
okay oh it was such a cool thing off Sal
a walk guys come sweet um okay I am
gonna use a grenade oh you got crossbow
I'm gonna use a grenade now when they
group off the nominees understand [ __ ]
you oh my god yeah I got a boat all
right he's dead that fat is not dead
next to you right next to you
okay I shot him in the butt that's just
I'll just keep
run away Chrissie you you [ __ ]
all right he's dead another guy over
here the crossbow guys kind of being a
pain I shot him
there's a guy with a wrench behind you I
got him
dropped his machete he's still running
around
[ __ ] it oh he's not stun he's not start
she was like hey
hi just killing you did zombies
my way cooler I pull out I guess [ __ ]
sight everybody you do is cooler all
right um turn this gameplay down a tiny
bit here our Sun our voices picked up
all this [ __ ]
all right where are we going I have a
portkey but I don't know what to do it
question back here you're back in the
building you got it in yeah I think if I
find it that's our to see where oh is it
here yes looks like it I found it oh
wait hold on don't go don't go forward
do not do it there's stuff up here I
think look up look up
press hold r2 I can see so many souls
fetching into the distance um seriously
though oh here we go emerald boom
nothing else I don't think people will
yell at me if I don't get everything but
such as the game alright
who do I hear
[Music]
what's up with your head has a bullet in
it I can push you toward him really are
you doing I was missing if I sprint I
can push you toward him am i doing that
that's kind of funny
that's a bad job well in your defense I
kind of push you again
okay wait come over here and stand still
or aim your gun I totally can push you
from behind if I'm sprinting that's
gonna be fun
keep your eyes peeled for more of that
no maybe back here some barrels
[Music]
this music is like too much there's just
like one dude that we haven't killed yet
that's what we're in could you do could
you do what's could you do I know the
port science I'd welcome to keep you you
quit jump down here check out this water
there's some dudes over there
how does something worthwhile they look
stumped others have herb over here let
me see where you're at I got it damn
that's impressive you see how easily she
left out of waist high water
dude again
Oh go watch watch me watch me all right
okay okay
I feel like you're not taking the series
make fun with it oh yeah if I wasn't
when I do this oh that's really cool
this one dudes throat-slitting
kill zombies back in the water wait he
was he wants to swim with me where'd he
go
it's not then jeez where is he that's
good you Carolyn I don't know nothing
happened right uh so they can't swim it
would appear when he jumped out of there
before oh maybe you just killed him on
the way there's something else like
there's another one
nothing disappointed there's nothing
about water yeah but in the water it's
not a thing it's deep man oh boy
oh okay I can't punch that guy very well
this guy like I hate these guys
who's this no hey come on down the
water's fine
Mary great got it oh god I'm on mammal
with that weapon she's got a got a got a
got a floor nice to take this fist
oh no he's alive like she was like ah oh
my I'm working on it I'm out of ammo for
everything are you sure yeah grenades
but you choose Alexis tiny mouth talking
it's summer season
nice all right it drops ammo let me have
it what's throwing all those Bulldogs at
me uh a guy with a flaming liquor bottle
a rude I needed that analyst on
Oh Oh what am i full of don't answer
that just [ __ ]
uh all right here we go oh my hey Mikey
from the sky where he's best don't do
not go out there yeah I got a clock tell
the [ __ ] stop is running forward and
triggering things putting my anger
hey Mikey Mikey I was it going hey I was
brooklyn been these days same ol just
kicked out letter not to you actually
come thinking i think where he where I
was just going don't take if I you're
gonna miss you don't take this down let
me come up here you all right there
buddy
jumping I'm going I'm leaving you behind
oh there's a good there's an herb over
here hey wait I want to heal well yeah
that sucks don't kick a lighter now when
I'm trying to come up to you I'm gonna
he'll come up here no I don't need your
help all right well I'm gonna heal by
myself
hey here's a guy behind you hey Mikey
wait go in they help you aerial support
keep that guy
you I don't think you need me nope you
you somersaulting everyone oh my my yo
you go way back wait was it where is it
it's so good of you right next to you he
just dropped some ammo of some sort I
need its handgun Emma
I just got the gold ah why's my nose
gentle son huh bad time nose hey Mike
use that you got with you with the
rocket launcher he's pretty good if I
don't say so myself Mickey Mantle
wouldn't even be hitting things that
good all right fruits taxi wait wait
there's a plant over here so I got it
there we go I got some rifle ammo huh we
get into that point don't we have you
been playing it that long no um
oh there's handgun ammo over here do you
want it yeah another stifle em over
there you're full but you could combine
some herbs you really want that rifle in
that badly I wouldn't say it won't let
me um it doesn't say full it look at me
okay there you go all right so wait let
me talk about this you could like
combine two green herbs okay how do I do
that
square square square and then uh and
then taken out so you have it once we
get rifles anything which door are we
going through I'm early room to the one
behind me I so check that out what's in
here both any souls here rifle sweet um
how do we do that we'll take it if you
took since you took the uh let me I'm
gonna heal us quick okay you don't
really need it but I don't have it right
here my but you want me to take the
rifle and we can all figure this out
later we swap I'm gonna hang for now
that's fine
I feel like for the purposes of the show
it would be cooler to have you use the
rifle uh-huh hey you seemed really good
with it in four but also you see me from
a distance rather than me I don't know
figure it out you know I'm saying like
it might be more interesting to watch
you ezel from the people viewing their
point of view mm-hmm I might be
overthinking it but yeah switch it up
but it's a nice change of pace I'll be
using for a little bit enjoy it because
I think I'm gonna need it coming up but
yeah if you haven't already I would
suggest swap moving your weapons and
grenades to uh like select I'm gonna do
that now because I keep accidentally
pulling out my first-aid spray yeah I
mean there's a square move them there's
nothing against I mean it's it's
sometimes nice to have first aid in like
one slot like the right so my grenade is
left
how do throwing grenades work in this
thing okay judging by four you're gonna
be awful at it but that is yeah and then
mp5 you could you could keep a first-aid
spray on there like I want to say don't
put grenades on there cuz I'm gonna need
on your quick select I would put a first
aid on your quick select rather than
that grenade on the left up to you it's
your style but I think you'd have to
pull out first aid in a hurry over a
grenade that makes sense yeah please
uh-oh here are some people oh hey you
break this crate
hello all right you know what [ __ ]
else is gonna [ __ ] do this the
heavily hey it's called the Rat King and
doctor Rosenfeld and I want your souls
it all Carl the Rat King came here to do
three things
chew bubblegum take your souls turn you
into rats and we're all out of bubblegum
I don't have any ammo um I kind of want
to like put one of my guns away or
something really he's a machine gun I
love you don't feel like rapidly fire
that you can just uh uh oh
come check out this bench see what it
says when you investigate it okay this
mean little foreshadowing of what's to
come wish we could pick up this double
chainsaw what were they doing here okay
probably sorry okay herb you need it I
cannot accept it
um could leave it for now Danny of the
rifle well this is dumb ah just come
here
can I give you this
first-aid spray exchange with your rifle
and I need ammo
now press triangle uh-huh oh you accept
that request circle maybe oh yeah hold
on with is the ammo that you wants the
one enough I'm gonna give you machine
gun I'm on you're gonna give me rifle
ammo okay so how do i I don't know no go
back go back
yeah give yeah yeah give I'm sorry my
bad I'd Beckett I was on the different
train of thought okay cool
uh so we I mean weird I get out of that
the machine gun ammo which I'm not gonna
use right now you got 60 bullets yeah
105 bowls for that it is so we're just
really bad yeah I guess so
actually you could give me that give me
a backer need one of those grenades why
because then I already have one so I
might see if you can give me that I'm
actually curious if grenades can stack
on one slot I don't know if they can
oh [ __ ] I did it wrong sorry oh sweet
okay okay that's good to know that
grenades yeah we did it we learned took
us a while but we are very dumb though
no kidding I was back where we started
how are we going back this way
oh hold on to your breakup and done that
I mean I have them out some what I'm
doing yeah go over this way okay I see
hey girl hey Mike oh no way being
attacked my bad names not Matheson it's
Mike you are those things pooping party
sick Mike Oh watch out
you knew there glammo gusting that's a
grenade I can't take it Mike you know
you got split up here back of this
ladder when you get the chance
hi you keep shooting him alright no
there are guys were next to you so take
that burn out first you take out all you
did not he threw an axe at me take out
our Mikey we take out yours okay here we
go stab you in the face if you don't
mind
Oh know how she flicks the blood off at
the end
machine gun away I'll take that all
right come back down this way I'm not
sure if this is like to progress or just
get something on the roof but you can
throw me up okay so people were asking
if we would if we could cut back and
forth between like me up there like up
here and when we split but the
post-production that would come in to
push us back our schedule so we're just
gonna stick to sticking on your screen
yeah it sucks I understand the
limitations between that especially cuz
I'm Way more fun to Watson Mary
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I need a grenade I know
I got it you got it so gay ladies thanks
bro if I don't say so myself it was okay
they're all except for this guy we need
to clean this up
wait watch me shoot this kind of head
like ah they're not all dead no mine
this is when the game becomes really fun
like when I'm covering you from on top
of the rifle you can stab to uh stop
that guy oh good don't know why we did
too long
thank you okay um I don't know if I can
jump down hand gun a Moore machine gun
I'm up here I don't know if it's worth
the trouble to get it for you though
that's all right I'm okay um I'm really
looking out for emblems I'm sure people
will have seen some that I don't you
just don't care that much although that
tells unlock some cool weapons inspired
outfits and [ __ ]
but we're not gonna like replay the game
anytime soon where are you going we see
you you see your little orange save me
some Souls please damn I got mad h GM o
hg wells get out my hg wells and pop a
cap in his ass handgun hg oh wow just
dude over here on the hill let me stab
he was just trying to take a so suck a
little pee he's in the shower nothing is
that now he's in the shower
I'm full of no these are like the tank
gonna mr. poop holes
oh I too actually don't know
mm okay um you can hmm I feel like that
the blue poll we do this trying to think
of how we get this red herb is how do
you spot how do you Neil you can really
try figure how we get this red herb
right here
I'm just trying only we can't squat
actually I think uh here's what we could
do
oh wait I had a green herb denied yeah
but yeah I can combine you need to pick
up the red herb first though can I just
drop something I'll drop anything you
don't have anything really worth
dropping hey five incendiary grenades
yeah I should use those yeah
whatever we'll find more better episode
Malloy did you get the hand get em over
here oh you can't I can't
I'm full we've been like full for a
while just go then that's you there's
plenty of ammo I just wanna come other
ready right there's plenty more where
can I drop it and then pick it back up
good question
I don't know Oh God
oh [ __ ] I got no I don't do when it says
discard does that mean like throw away I
honestly don't remember I think so yes
it might be worth double-checking at
some point I wanted to do it
[Music]
keep in mind like at the end we can
always rearrange items but like I said
we're not gonna it's not a lack of
reading that I want to do with something
cool getting from behind oh I forgot or
the uppercut well I don't know what your
behind thing is all right let's do that
next time
uh hold on though cuz I wanna see us
through here well I really can't because
there's a guy a knife that's not a knife
oops this is a knife
you get one I'll get the other I waited
too long again or it didn't give me the
prompts or I suck ha ha ha ha
err juggle Chumlee [ __ ] who would you
be you be for you now there's a hand
grenade over here got it no in here I'll
take another one I don't I'm gonna the
max yet Jesus how many do I have
I really need to use my grenades there's
like an abundance of ammo and that's the
part where we split up and then have to
cover each other so what is this Gears
of War try oh this came out before Gears
of War did it I don't remember actually
a handgun I'll stat I got my rifle and
this handgun I'm over here if you're not
fooling I am full alright man you sound
agitated I forgot you were full okay
let's go you gotta throw me over there
excuse me I forgot you were full watch
this like watch what they do neo and
Trinity okay here we go what am i doing
not that I haven't defied physics wait
what am i doing ah you're going you
gotta cover me from there I think that's
it
each other I guess yeah just kind of
shoot stuff and oh no you got a lot of
[ __ ] going on
you got them I have a rifle which is
unfortunate for this part oh dude you
[ __ ] this up oh it's fine it wouldn't I
Sheva has to be the one that comes over
here I know but I should have the rifle
I
think this far Adam it's fine I dealt
with worse in the residue okay all right
you know what [ __ ] threw a wrench and
what is that there's a grenade
blow up thank you all right I'm going
company
[ __ ] your move [ __ ] you I don't know
where you are I'm just shooting anything
in the back yeah fine I might be feeling
really fast I'm down ground floor now
come on what does that mean I'm on the
ground floor am I supposed to cover you
down there uh if you can't he can you go
climb back down yet I'm fine honestly I
just need to unlock that door for you to
come out here I made a lot of cool stuff
happening on your end back down she
jumped down don't worry about covering
me anymore I got this seems like seems
like you're having a good time
I am I go back down the stairs the way
you came
there we go about to video game select
from the other side
how's it going [ __ ] people up I'm
gonna unlock it up watching you do like
really cool back there here here here
here please [ __ ] gotta reload all right
son luck no it's not one more
it's unlike oh there's a barrel there
I'm gonna shoot it oh my god oh [ __ ] I
shouldn't have done that yet I remember
this part now I should not have wasted
that barrel I thought is where we'll
define this machine gun over there you
can take that we got another stoppies
don't shoot that barrel yet say that um
a lot of guys here this is not a breaker
oh that's pretty cool
pratik oh [ __ ] I'm gonna pick that up I
gotta have some [ __ ] I don't need this
machine gonna wear it out
[ __ ] I gotta reload
I don't know why but I thought that
could pause do not know
nice yeah don't try not to go forward
too much I want to trigger this change
like I have we can help it unless
they're scheduled a lot of animal to
collect I'm full on everything
I'm empty on Chaka let me give you a
your full on machine gun as well that's
a time I got only Killa
don't I not keep taking machine I don't
want I need shotgun arrow for the rifle
come here let me give this to you at
least what's your entire life
mmm there you go let me meet Dean it's a
gather some [ __ ] it was some of these
guys chainsaw guys coming up handgun
nice wood night any clear out anybody
the second floor farce fun i fund there
dude it was really boring on my end
until you [ __ ] came through in the
nick of time and didn't really do much
the hold it that's correct
okay the audience did not get to see
anything cool the coolest way to watch
that would have been for you to have the
rifle I just didn't think that boy had
I'm not like lamb I have clairvoyant
alright I guess I'm supposed to be in
this series so I'm not really a guy
anymore more of a your Shiba I'm gonna
clear a sheva she was Shiva's a better
name yeah it is
[ __ ] sounds cool alright let's do
this
say that Barrel in over here knows have
a bus there's a barrel up here you're on
the bus sir you're off yo come over here
I gotta show you something okay I mean
we need the chance I'm coming just right
I got a green herb
wait do you have room cuz if you could
get that red orb that'd be cool
I don't but look at this it's graffiti
is pretty phat
all right let's go joke landed oh my god
here we go Oh with the chuckling for huh
[ __ ] back out of here soon coming up
on a good time to end this episode
what's that yeah you notice we have new
microphones in here
those are nice those are very that's a
nice blade you got his headed always got
one IRA I was a around and run oh you're
gonna be first I turn around shoot that
barrel there's other guys though I'm
gonna shoot the barrel you kill those
guys in front of us we I want to watch
it though all right turn around turn
around
I did it I did it Oh God there he's
right behind you I think
let's get inside a building or something
okay
hey there's a barrel over here
I gotta throw a grenade come back this
way your corner yourself I'll do the
door on the other side to say you know
oh nice nice eh a barrel miss okay
doctor come back out front I can help
you out unless you come on me remember
double double tap square opens with our
faster no I like to open it carefully
gingerly all right where'd he go
I got a grenade ready for him oh [ __ ]
come on hit it yeah kind of full marker
and kind of one more cool somersault BAM
[ __ ] you alright little right pulling
from a distance yeah go up the stairs or
a Niram don't pour it I'm not good at
very merry alright okay
oh that might kill me he's gonna kill me
oh yeah run oh sorry sorry it's kind of
my fault for leading us up there but I
thought I am just bad at this well kill
him then we'll in the episode and on a
good note
uh not [ __ ] uh actually wait we could
take this moment to I'd like to organize
better because I could've gotten move
this handgun ammo up take that like do
we need three guns here uh like I'll
take my meat there's okay so that you
got thirty machine gun I'm on your
inventory might as well take that what
there's thirty ammo and our shared
inventory already good I'd like to move
my handgun to my inventory can I do that
or no you don't want the third gun just
a lot of inventory space sure I guess so
you don't I mean sure I'm just confused
I'm just confused what a green herb in
there um something treasured before damn
we got a bunch of these do I need to use
my incendiaries but I died last time I
tried to use them can you give me some
shotgun ammo so I'd like to move this
Shino keep your chakra's my Dona chakra
was this when I hit remove does that put
it in my inventory yep alright yeah I
understand now okay I'm ready are you
ready I'm getting ready you have 60
seconds sure let's kill this [ __ ] I'm
bad at this
alright wait actually there's an area
over here we didn't know okay I got that
hey I can find it yet yeah I mean it's
not gonna matter if your chainsaws you
but try not to let that happen
oh wait hon I gotta show you something
it does matter if he chainsaws me it
killed me come over here I need to show
you something where
what can I do I just check out this phat
graffiti oh my god
rules 1/3 I'll probably do that one
again okay rule of three math isn't
removal if they're just cameras yeah you
know how it feels for me to trigger keep
touch pad this unit please okay run that
barrel
I'll do the barrel again
[ __ ] all right I'm gonna do this
a-hole a shotgun I'm gonna do this whole
way again all right he got Sun we should
have taken more advantage that he's
coming after me I think watch your
animal you got nothing left in your gun
right now
right
all right he's coming over here to you
yeah yeah I mean I'll come I'll bring
over there just hang on a second come
yep
hi well I want to do what I want to do
it alright yeah my wait he's right there
I'll do it if you don't thank you ghost
go hit him go him what somersaulted
that's my move okay don't let go you
feel like you actually just tried to
hurt me you're like II do that cool
somersault move Oh Wayne that we know
well it's my yeah that's not I meant
I'm just pistol him right oh I got him I
got him I got him Gavin twist kitchen I
don't know but he's getting hurt
come over in here and show the people
what they want to see [ __ ]
come on a dick broke her neck he's
pretty easy to dodge you go on his off
shoulder I'm gonna stab his kind of face
while you handle him got him
it's ND what oh there's a guy behind you
go kick him if you get time I'm a
recovering man he's taking a lot oh yeah
go to the grenades
Wow it's ineffective that should have
watch out watch out he's pretty easy to
dad yet No
oh [ __ ] no not again
yeah just run through that door okay
back out here is gonna hear him so
doggie idiot I wanna kill you exactly
what happened last time let me take that
haha now I watch one block he's right
behind us we just run just run up here
and shotgun a buddy's honey
lucky you are you stunned from here my
grenades cover me
oh that's a surgery I got right thank
you wait what's that
don't you transformer down there what is
that I don't know what that is it's
gonna hurt house not dead
back up back up I can't marry I can't
got you I got you
no coolant up here dodging how do I get
around him I don't know how to dodge run
just run right on his shoulder
Mary [ __ ] wait hold on he's gonna throw
no not the corner I'm coming up coming
up coming just don't die okay
run away virgin oh man really bad I'll
just keep going I'm just gonna run away
uh shoot him a few okay what are you
doing hey don't heal
oh it's grenade thank you I thought you
were like house not dead you okay - just
taking so much thank you that'd be
awesome that was a thing special ops
thank you [ __ ] sorry I'm sorry
really hard dammit I'm not doing super
hot yeah you sound like E all right we
did it
oh wait [ __ ] look at look at what
happens when she kill him
this fack rafidhi pops up oh I'm not
even looking what's L 3 x 2 on it's a
weird I honestly don't know but just tap
the stick twice it'll go away it's
something to do with coop
Nega that's weird idol you know the
animal possible I think so
God seems like it I barely survived that
I have a lot of money to spend on [ __ ]
really struggled with changing weapons
alright I don't have the guards to back
apparently did we share yeah you really
got focused on the what use for quick
select a lot of gold there I guess we
thought that well the grenades are one
thing so I understand that all right
cool we're off
better better episode than last time
last time we're still getting the hang
of things only I'm doing super hot like
any team he did my best takes a while to
mesh I think it's the end of the chapter
okay cool hot scene but we can wait and
see uh still good time to end it we can
pick up from here okay uh Mary what are
you thinking over as evil five so far
after this okay I feel like the AI is
pretty dumb uh which is a bummer that
I'm like dying a lot cuz that says a lot
about me um it's okay I enjoy playing it
with you like I'm glad you're here I
think if I played this by myself I would
not care for this game
oh yeah it's co-op it's better in
general
alright next time on the penultimate
episode an ultimate resident evil thank
you guys for watching don't forget to
Like and subscribe this video it does
help us make these more see ya hey check
the way say good bye bye